in a new lawsuit two former Google
engineers claim the company is a hostile
workplace for employees with
conservative views a suit filed
yesterday in California also alleges the
company discriminates against men and
white employees by unfairly favoring
women in some minorities in hiring and
promotions one of the engineers James
tomorrow was fired in August after
posting controversial opinions to an
internal Google message board CBS News
legal analyst Ricky Clement is here
Ricky good morning good morning a lot of
people say this is rich I saw a lot of
eye rolls this morning when we were just
talking about it upstairs because white
men dominate most industries including I
look around the room a lot of white men
in this room so it seems very hard to
understand how you could have a case
well especially when the discrimination
against a white man especially at first
blush when you look at Google Google has
males are 69% of its population women
are 31% of his population and when you
look at race whites are 59% of its
population followed in great proportion
by agents and then other minorities oh
this is confusing well it's not only
confusing I first bless you say to
yourself oh come come on we all know
that when we read about Silicon Valley
we have read countless tales of women
saying I can't get jobs if I get jobs I
can't get a promotion I'm not taken
seriously and on it goes
however when you delve into this 161
page complaint and you've read it I did
read every bit of it and it's really
there in graphic detail including
internal memoranda lots of emails lots
of things that were on the boards as
well as tweets what you do when you go
into the company itself is you also have
to look at the law and the law is the
surprise you have a very good lawyer
here Ms Dylan is someone who has brought
cases for a class of people who feel
that they are white males and that they
have been discriminated against she has
also looked at this industry and looked
at conservative speech and what she
looks at also are the campuses and other
places where conservative speaker is
called to
speak is basically shot down and shot
out and she says that's what's happening
here so how can a white man file
discrimination I'm still confused by
that well let's look at his history
we're looking at him as the person who
wants to represent the plaintiff class
he is someone who has had excellent
reviews superb reviews
he has gotten salary increases bonuses
stock options all the way up he goes and
he goes as if he has a stellar career
then he winds up at diversity meetings
when they have these weekly and monthly
meetings and he hears that not only are
hiring preferences going to go to women
and minorities but so our promotional
preferences and what he says is wait a
minute I am just as equally qualified so
why should I be shut out
remember to conservative point of view
is a separate element here that's the
nuts and bolts of this case we are shut
down and shut up
so he says so interesting we should just
know to Google spokesperson issued a
statement saying quote we look forward
to defending against mr. d'amours
lawsuit in court riki cleamen thank you
so much